what up space fam goals and here from
anime upper and i'm back to discuss the
full translated chapter of the one piece
story and oh boy it fills in a lot that
the spoilers didn't including more news
about the legendary shanks the fate of
sabo we get a better idea of green
bull's power we even get the exact name
of the fruit revealed and him using it
in insane ways and yeah it's gonna be
impressive and much more so make sure to
stay tuned for that chill the pirate
king with it and smash that like button
if you enjoyed these weekly one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming be
a smashing pirate king rather than
passing orochi and youtube will reward
you with fireworks true story make this
the video you joined the knockout by
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates now it's
time again to thank the one and only
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
video this awesome mobile game also
available for pc keeps growing and now
has over 600 champions for you to
collect and fight with including top
tier waifus which as we all know is
always my top priority use my qr code or
links below right now to download raid
yourself to your mobile phone or pc one
of the really cool aspects of this game
is that all the champions come from
unique factions each with their own
history in the world of talaria one of
my faves is the high elves who've been
around for thousands of years surviving
everything from orc rampages to the
collapse of the lizard man empire then
the lord of darkness got into their
heads and created the dark elves like
elves but edgier they wanted to take
over the kingdom with shadow magic and
civil war followed in the end the dark
elves were exiled and the elf kingdom
arabia was rebuilt and even became the
brightest richest and most powerful
country in tellurium i love stacking my
teams with elves like elhane and sniper
and arbiter has to be one of my favorite
waifus a ton is happening in raid this
month including five new badass
champions that i can't wait to get my
hands on on top of that raid's running a
huge series of summer splash events for
the whole month where you can get your
hands on some incredible skins for my
favorite dwarf trunda new players can
use my link or scan the qr code right
here and you will get a free starter
pack worth almost 30 dollars a free
champion aina and also this cool in-game
loot so there's arguably never been a
better time to start playing you will
find your rewards here in your inbox for
the next 30 days only and now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all we heard about the one piece
cover spread in the spoilers and it
sounded hype it was about the four new
emperors after all and i gotta say
looking at it now it did not disappoint
all of the yonko look amazing and i
especially love seeing buggy here i
really do want to hang this on my wall
but anyways let's head to the chapter
which if you watch the spoiler vid you
know it's called flame emperor and yes
there's an epic reason for that title
but more on that later we catch up to
green bull first who was approaching the
party last chapter he says to himself
the ability to sway others that really
is something you don't see very often
and quote we see flowers sprouting from
beneath his feet as he walks and says
the stuff of course this quote makes me
think of conquerors hockey in particular
and luffy specifically the ability to
enact your will on other living things
and to have others want to help you and
follow you we see that the samurai are
in green bull's path and he tells them
and i quote you samurai should buzz off
while you can end quote they don't
obviously they want to protect luffy but
then green bull snaps he talks about how
celestial dragons are gods and how a
country like wano with no ties to the
world government has no standing we see
his move flexing forest muscle giant
fist-shaped roots spring out from the
ground as do flowers and trees he
proclaims he's a forest man who ate the
forest for his fruit his logia power is
nature incarnate a source of life that
rivals the seas now that is definitely a
very hype fruit way back when i thought
he might have a plant fruit and that's
sort of similar to what ended up
happening but here he's definitely
hyping it up as something much more the
seas are a huge force in one piece one
that happens to be super effective
against fruit users and saying he rivals
it he's nature itself is just a very big
deal arguably a bigger deal than if he
just had your mid-tier mythical zone we
then get some bad guy philosophy from
greenball he says it's time they learned
the hard truth humanity only got this
far by enforcing hierarchies he
continues saying and i quote we've got
to put non-affiliate nations like yours
in their place that order is what keeps
life going prejudice breeds stability
end quote this is classic shonen where
even the antagonists have philosophies
which make them at least in their own
eyes the good guys for me it's what
always separated anime from those
childhood cartoons where the villains
even acknowledge being villains
themselves think dr draken from kim
possible in this case it's green bulls
duty to maintain hierarchy by disposing
of outliers and non-conformists or else
in his view chaos will follow and
humanity will regress or potentially
wipe itself out it's great seeing his
forest form attacking the scabbards and
the scabbards cutting the roots even
while greenville towers over them in the
panel it's funny his head kinda makes
him look like a talking piece of
broccoli he points out that no laws
would be broken if they all died here he
says they can try to stop him but he'll
take down thousands of people if that's
what it takes to get luffy yamato then
comes in saying every word you just said
makes me sick using conker's haki yamato
hits him in the face and it's a great
panel even green bull after being hyped
up so much recently says man that hurt
that's some hockey you've got right
there momo joins in with his dragon form
they want to let wano celebrate their
liberty after 20 years of tyranny but
again greenville is not one who cares
about freedom freedom is actually a
threat to hierarchy we get a funny
emphasized moment where momo is about to
launch a blast breath like it really
gets a big panel but nothing comes out
yeah he's definitely not ready to defend
wano from serious threats and that's
what makes me fear that yamato might end
up staying behind despite wanting to be
a straw hat props to momo though even if
he's not strong yet he's brave and runs
into aramaki's forest god form and bites
him saying i will drive you from the
capital be gone aramaki is at first
surprised by the pink dragon thinking
he's never heard of this ability and
then he wraps his roots around momo's
dragon body clearly being the one with
the advantage in the fight or at least
it seems nevertheless momo tells yamato
to stay out of this to everyone's shock
in classical fashion during this very
interesting moment where we want to know
what happens next and what momo is
talking about we skip to another moment
but it's definitely forgivable
considering where we skipped too
although before completely moving on i
want to add i wonder if momo is actually
saying this because he knows yamato will
leave and he wants to know if they can
handle this on their own like they would
have to in the future it'll be
interesting to see why he didn't want
yamato to get involved but as
interesting as that was we now jump to
the most hyped moment of the chapter in
my opinion although there's plenty more
after it we jump to the seas around wano
where we catch up to shanks's own ship
that's right yonko shanks as we learned
in the spoilers is pretty much at wano
they're discussing how luffy is really a
yonko now and that it's surreal it's
suggested for them to go to luffy since
luffy's become a great pirate as you'll
remember that was their deal luffy will
give back the straw hat when he fulfills
the promise of becoming a great pirate
and now shanks is so close to him after
25 years of the one piece manga shanks
remarks that last time he was here they
were giving odin a send-off and of
course he is referring to when he was on
roger's crew he even thinks about how
momo and hiri must be all grown up now
lucky roo says let's go see luffy
already yasuo though says he's not ready
to meet usop yet and i love that even
kid is brought up they say he's here too
and that it hasn't been that long since
that brat tried to pick a fight with
them i really love that they mentioned
that kid detail because that's a side
thread i really find fascinating also
it's proved that kid didn't lie to get
some clout he actually fought the red
hair pirates we see shanks looking at
luffy's new wanted poster we enter into
flashback first we see shanks and crew
attacking the ship with cp9 agents that
held the gomu gomu no me even the
marines were confused saying it's not
like we've got any proper treasure only
some minor devil fruit again all of this
seems to further confirm what i've been
saying the whole time that shanks knew
about the truth of the gomu no me then
we get flashbacks of the village days
where he bonded with village boy luffy
and he even remembers when he sacrificed
his arm for him the fact that he started
the flashback with the fruit and not
luffy also further lends to the idea
that he knows the importance of the
fruit and now he's seen its awakened
form in the new poster he must be
thinking his sacrifice was clearly worth
it as he smiles looking at the poster we
see fresher recruits surprised that the
top officers have a history with luffy
we get a unique moment where members of
the red hair pirates react to the rumors
about luffy saying that he's a rampaging
demon monkey that's totally out of
control it makes sense that these kinds
of legends would surround luffy
considering how far he's come but it's
still cool to see especially because we
are usually seeing the story from
luffy's perspective and are not privy to
such talk but then shanks shuts our
hopes down and yeah i'm kind of sad
about it i mean they're so close and
luffy is a great pirate but alas shanks
says he is not planning on having a
reunion with luffy here roo and the
others are shocked he says they gotta go
to deal with problems in their own
backyard like that bart guy who claimed
to be under luffy and who put his mark
up after burning down the red hair
pirates flag this seems like an
interesting shout out to the grand fleet
but the implications are potentially big
it's said they can't fail their duties
by letting that slide but if they do
deal with bart what will that mean for
the straw hat and red hair dynamic
clearly this talk encourages us to view
them as rivals rather than allies and i
just want to see them meet again but
then again it would be weird if luffy
returned to straw hat their shanks as
agreed since that's kind of his thing
now and probably will be until the end
so i do see why oda might want to wait
but it's such an unbelievably big tease
having shanks this close and for them
not to meet especially since luffy has
pretty much fulfilled his end of the
deal shanks even asks ben isn't it about
time they go and claim it meaning the
one piece we see a serious shanks
expression which is epic that was what
we were waiting for since we found out
that shanks couldn't go to the final
island because buggy was sick and he
stayed with him saying they'll go with
their own ship one day again i'm hoping
if we don't get a shank straw hat
alliance at least we get a shanks buggy
alliance but we'll see the spoilers
didn't give us a lot to work with so i
was hoping maybe shanks and luffy would
meet then see about the one piece
together but no shanks is going to be
his rival here it seems and try to get
it before luffy in a sense this does
make sense because luffy probably needs
more worthy rivals in the story after
taking down the so-called strongest
creature in the world is it just me
though or does ben look hella tired when
he's shown this dude does not look like
a guy excited to go on a grand adventure
but more like a retiree at this point
i'm hoping he's okay and is just one of
those strong dudes who just happen to
think things are a drag like shikamaru
but we'll figure that out later anyways
after that insanity we get more at navy
headquarters we learn all the juicy
information about the revolutionaries
and sabo in particular and oh my god it
is juicy kainu aka akainu but i'm gonna
say akainu as usual is told they can't
let the revolutionary army go unchecked
any longer he says he knows but they
don't have any marines to deploy and now
i quote the one they're calling flaming
emperor sabo he's become a champion for
much of the world end quote we're told
that out of all the participants at the
reverie the one killed was a descendant
of one of the founding 20 from 800 years
ago it's none other than cobra vivi's
father i shared my thoughts on this in
the spoiler video but long story short
it's probably sabo being framed whether
it's by blackbeard or imusama is yet to
be revealed if sabo were to take down
one of the rulers why go after an
arguably good ruler when there are so
many bad ones to choose from either way
whatever actually happened it's quite
the symbolic action for the
revolutionaries not only has the
government not caught them but they even
failed to catch them after they took out
one of the world's acknowledged leaders
clearly the world government does not
look strong in that situation
furthermore a few hours before that they
attacked the homes of the celestial
dragons in the holy land destroying a
monument of the divine dragon claw and
the symbol of the world nobles it was a
blatant declaration of war they say even
admirals aramaki and fujitora were not
enough to prevent the revolutionaries
from freeing kuma from celestial dragon
slavery aside from kobra's death
obviously which does suck the rest is
amazing to hear without dragon his
commanders clashed with two admirals and
succeeded yeah it probably wasn't a
decisive victory in terms of defeating
the admirals but even being able to hold
them back long enough to escape with
kuma is beyond impressive we're told
that princess vivi went missing which
will be a big mystery that needs to be
revealed for a while i'm sure but we do
know that imusama seemed to be after
vivi so there could be a connection
there and some people may well ask was
it blackbeard who again took advantage
of a commotion to get devin to
impersonate sabo and then kidnap vivi it
remains to be seen but as i mentioned in
the spoiler video it's possible that
blackbeard moved in to take over
alabasta after the rulers disappeared
we're then introduced to black horse the
navy criminal affairs unit chief and
these guys named with these color and
animal patterns are usually always op so
he's one to watch out for akainu says
alabasta is in chaos he bets again a
good opportunity for blackbeard to swoop
in we're really starting to understand
what aramaki was recently talking about
about the marines being in a bad
position and the world being in chaos
outside of wano kizaru mentions the
attempted murder of saint charlos and if
they can close the case of course this
was a super annoying dude luffy punched
in the most satisfying way possible
apparently though another celestial
dragon excuse the criminals akainu adds
that in the holy land the gods knights
have jurisdiction so he says to leave
the case to them it's interesting seeing
akainu in this position he definitely
seems to have changed since his admiral
days and no longer seems as hot-headed
and stubborn as before black horse says
most incidents are linked to sabo and
that his flames of rebellion are
spreading over the globe and yes how
perfect is that line flames of rebellion
for sabo who has the flame flame fruit
it's it's great i love that line it's
amazing we're told all eight of those
rebelling kingdoms were inspired to
stage their revolutionary coups while
their kings were still returning home he
says it's almost like they are
worshiping sabo as a god with the growth
of his legend they're saying his
influence is now greater than that of
dragon himself who as we all know is
sabo's leader pretty crazy stuff and i
gotta say i'm happy to see sabu's
reputation exploding including the
reputation of the revolutionaries in
general i'm glad sabo wasn't just left
behind in the dust by luffy in terms of
influence these brothers are killing it
and you love to see it and kizuru points
that out saying on top of that his
little brother has been dubbed a yonko
people are even citing luffy as just
another example of sabo's influence at
work in the pirate world they say sabo's
brother upended the status quo and right
now times are being forced to change
akainu actually comes off as really cool
here saying he became fleet admiral at a
crazy time but he doesn't care where
they attack from the marines will strike
back and return fire on all fronts it's
crazy to see the once overbearing and
powerful world government in a situation
like this it's also exciting when you
think about them the revolutionaries
shanks going for the one piece
blackbeard buggy and so on right now we
should all be thinking what a time to be
alive what a time to be a one piece fan
this is crazy amazing stuff chill the
pirate king within and smash that like
button if you enjoyed this review and
want to keep them coming be a smashing
pirate king rather than passing orochi
and like i said youtube will reward you
with fireworks true story test it out
make this the video you joined to not
come up by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates you guys
can let me know if i was correct but i
believe i was right when i first saw
from the spoilers that this would be a
10 out of 10 chapter let me know if you
agree in the comments even though yes it
would have been even crazier if shanks
actually went to meet luffy lastly as
you wait for the new one-piece videos
and updates to come out feel free to
check out my growing one-piece playlist
that includes videos in all the yonko
warlords admirals mythical zones and
much more linked to that is in the
description and on screen right now by
the way you can also check out my almost
one hour long shanks video so that's
definitely something to check out if you
have time and if you love shanks as far
as i know it's the longest shanks video
on youtube anyways drop a hashtag sabo
in the chat if you're a real one and
watch all the way to the end and until
next time see you space cowboys